oh hello grandmaster Maxime Draghi yeah
that's a good one
not sure do we on one at the moment he
does this is show here right the take it
to the max show maybe I don't know it's
y'all maybe just place like that just
just for fun and we'll see mm-hmm it
seems he also it's not really knowing
this opening so well it's not a
particularly good good set up I think
maybe I'm mistaking yeah maybe I am
mistaken but as far as I know and this
is good for white Joe it looks good for
white okay so that's good
yeah I got the G file open and yeah that
looks good
so Ruchi one ayah max is actually online
I mean broadcasting is what I'm trying
to say so Bishop h6 he's got Luke f7 I
really would have liked to be in some
better shape here when I plane I have a
good score against Julie big plus three
against four three one okay so he has to
do some of some funky stuff him age six
is going back Beshear age five it's not
decisive so after iPhone that g5 all
night age form
doesn't look very nice what is he doing
now age six hmm I don't know h6 I don't
see a clear refutation and maybe I can
just take you five I can just take you
five here right check this is
devastating it looks pretty good at
least if he takes that Bishop c5 it's
pretty pretty good okay I'm just cleanly
two would be should be three or
something just complete development
I usually don't do don't do badly
against her three one scholar said so
what now trading the light squared
bishop would be very very cool so I'm
going to do that to have ninety four and
so on he is a quick he's very quick so I
don't want you take take too long also
make sure that getting into you time
issues night if five is this coming here
mm-hmm-hmm I don't like 95 I don't like
the don't like the look of that but I
can take aged six right what's the big
deal
he will probably play the bishop
somewhere it's not it's not totally
decisive though
okay come on I just Castle him I don't
think that this can be all that terrible
he's got going to check night a three
maybe yeah this is a small problem what
about Bishop t4 by the way check cream
cakes look cheeks and then darling there
are no it's called Queen a for now
that's a bad idea
I don't want that I can take aged six
though this should work
let's take it
and 93 coming with this and Knight f3
hmm I had and no Queenie fo it doesn't
look clearly enough to me somehow okay I
have to claim and I'm already implying
this badly giving him far too many
chances this was a completely lost
position and now it's messy it's really
messy night c4 yes good night c4
I don't really see a good move against
that community to 1990 section okay no
we just do it well hmm
I did not think about this at all okay I
don't understand this position this is
the core of the problem I really have no
idea what's going on
you're just a total mess and I usually
don't do well in total messes 94 maybe a
three or something I have no idea my d3
American check on e4 that's what a
Messer has really really screwed that up
was such a completely winning position
and this is as I said not clear at all
right c4 I might have given to be three
time warning it's doing that it's good
b5 and I cannot take this actually well
let's get out of this 50 something
seconds the time will be very crucial
him so let's see if I can take you for
keeps the tension here I don't get near
skin this is really a really messed up
i-i'll playing here from this who I was
completely winning and now it's the
other way around and it wasn't necessary
but it's so probably good for him check
check-check
nice no it's so difficult yeah to handle
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check managed to do it oh my goodness
yeah this was okay no comments no
comments I have to finish the game more
fun 20 or something I was just so
winning Jack amazing stuff yeah I
couldn't finish him off
I mean they were probably tons of ways
to do that and I couldn't do it I simply
couldn't do it ah yeah this is this is
an unimportant pause I guess I have to
do something which is easier to manage
this is the thing it's just kind of kind
of messy and something whatever Quincy
to me at all wins and now it gets it
gets already very very shaky g7 yeah
okay the computer gives gives me win
every move I mean that's it's really
really kind of pointless I just have to
find one of the hosts
it's a Gannon plus 3 or whatever but I'd
simply don't finish him off you just
continue then continues and at the end
he tricks me yeah I mean he was winning
before but he went into this ending but
the real thing is I have to the game has
to be finished
here so yeah maybe this is actually
helping him and I should cancel him yeah
it's a known each other nice it's the
position that you just have to win
pretty much regardless of who's who the
black players and yeah I don't know the
other games I win against not this time
not this time it was really messy and
they played very some very I know
surprising who's taking this why not 93
which I actually overlooked and this 7
is also winning now this and it's easy
it's easy stuff I have to trade a strong
Bishop and after that I just win in the
attack him in his King has no cover but
just a very bad game ok guys thanks for
watching